sound engineer John a Boehner worked on
groundbreaking films like the Poseidon
Adventure and the towering inferno he
also served as an academy governor
representing the sound branch and he was
a chair of the SCI tech committee his
volunteer work and dedication to the
academy spanned more than 30 years and
in 1994 he was awarded an academy medal
of commendation for his years of service
his devotion was so impactful that after
his death two years later the very medal
he won was renamed for him and tonight
surely Bona John's wife is here with us
yes where is he
those who have been honored with the
medal are part of an esteemed group
carefully chosen for their dedication
some of that group have joined us
tonight for our celebration if you could
please stand
tonight we hand the John a Boehner award
to a man whose core beliefs of the very
definition of this honor the pursuit of
upholding high standards in the science
of motion pictures Curtis Clarke
Wow Wow Wow - Curtis Clark the Academy
is proud to present the John a Boehner
award
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a little bit overwhelming I have
to admit I'm used to doing things they
bestow recognition on the colleagues
that I work with so to be the recipient
of this is really quite remarkable and
also but I want to start by thanking
obviously the Academy SciTech awards
committee and the Academy Board of
Governors for this absolutely tremendous
honor I first experienced the seductive
power of cinema as a young boy in a
downtown Nacogdoches Texas theater where
my grandmother took me to an afternoon
matinee of High Noon
I was so transfixed with a sense of
wonder that I pleaded with my
grandmother to let me see it again
at the next showing which she did do the
film had effectively created a world
where I became immersed in an
emotionally charged atmosphere for me
the attraction of cinematography has
always been the aesthetic role that it
plays in sharing narrative storytelling
through compelling images that instill
the viewer with a sense of wonder it was
many years later at the London Film
School that I felt compelled to
understand the technical foundation of
the motion picture image to better
explore the artistic possibilities at
that time motion pictures were in a
exclusively film based system when
digital cinema started to emerge as a
reality the American Society of
Cinematographers asked me to form a
Technology Committee later renamed
motion imaging technology Council to
assess these new digital imaging
technologies with a view to influence
their development in ways that best
serve the creative work of
cinematography and the filmmaking
process January 2019 marked the 100th
anniversary of the ANC and the 16th
anniversary of our Technology Council
during the past 16 years we have
achieved significant success in forged a
formidable reputation as an important
forum that focuses on the ways that
digital imaging technologies impact our
additional cinematographic art form and
how they can best serve filmmakers
creative intent I would also like to
thank those dedicated individuals who
have consistently contributed their
considerable talents and the work of our
agency Technology Council I'd also like
to thank my wife Margie who has been
remarkable in the last 36 years of our
married life in supporting my wacky
crazy notions of what I think is
important in impacting our family life
in certain instances and of course my
son Jonathan and his wife Emily who are
here with me tonight thank you very much
[Applause]